-Welcome to the show.
-Thanks, man.
Nice to be here.
-This is very fun
to see you in a comedy.
I feel like we know
you from more serious roles.
Are you enjoying doing
something that's funny?
-This is the best job
in the world.
Although, I was funny on
"The Practice" and
"American Horror Story."
-Yeah? Oh, really?
-Right?
-Oh, okay.
I maybe slightly missed
the jokes, yeah.
And then you hosted
"SNL" in 1999.
You met Will Ferrell
and you met Adam McKay,
the head writer
at "SNL" at the time.
And they brought this
idea to you.
Was it pretty much a no-brainer
when you hear from
guys like this,
that they want you
to star in their comedy?
-Oh, my God. Are you kidding me?
Have you seen the show?
Captain Dave?
-Yeah, it's perfect.
-The greatest role ever.
-Yeah.
-I mean, I just -- I love it.
-And you get to have a mustache.
That's your mustache.
-Most importantly, yes.
-Did you base your mustache
on any historic mustaches?
-You know, when I
started to read the script,
the mustache started to
spontaneously grow by itself.
-Oh, my God.
-Which was weird.
-Yeah.
The mustache
jumped off the page.
-It did.
-Yeah.
But, I mean, you have to look at
the history of mustaches.
Who has the best mustache ever?
-I mean, Selleck.
-Selleck. Yeah.
-Yeah.
-You got to start there.
And then you
move down to Burt Reynolds.
-Yeah.
No, that's a pretty good one.
Not very far down.
He's right beneath him, yeah.
-And then you've got to
go to Captain Dave.
-Yeah.
Oh, you're third all time?
-I'm third all time.
-I'm very jealous, because I was
hoping it was a fake mustache,
but I can tell that
you grew your own.
I cannot grow my own mustache,
and it's very
heartbreaking for me,
because my father has a good --
a thick, bushy mustache.
-Nice.
-And, yet,
I did not get that DNA.
But do you mind?
Can I put a mustache on
for the rest of the interview?
-I would love that.
-Great. Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Couple of guys with mustaches.
-Wow.
Yeah, totally.
-Wait a second.
Let's go side by side.
-Right there.
Oh, no. We'll go over here.
We'll go to 3.
It's a good mustache.
-I love it.
-You --
-Tell me.
-You did stand-up.
You used to try stand-up.
You did stand-up
at the Comedy Cellar,
maybe the most famous
comedy place --
stand-up place in New York.
-But before we get into that,
I want to give you something.
I got you something.
-Oh.
This is very exciting.
-No, that's my license.
Yeah, I got you this.
-This is...Heidi Klum Intimates?
-Yeah.
-Why did you get me this?
-I can't talk about it.
-Okay.
I like that you leave the house,
and you're like,
"I need two things --
my driver's license
and some Heidi Klum Intimates."
These are...
These go over the nipple.
-That's right.
[ Clears throat ]
-All right.
I mean, I put on a mustache.
-Yeah, you might as well.
-So, anyways, you go at the
Cellar, and it didn't go great?
-So, yeah, I did
Catch A Rising Star,
The Bitter End,
and then, you know, I was
feelin' myself a little bit.
I did the Comedy Cellar.
-Mm-hmm.
-And I'm up there,
and it's not going well.
-Mm-hmm. How'd you know?
-Well, no one's laughing.
-Yeah, that's how you know.
-So, when no one laughs --
and it was really crickets --
they pulled me offstage
and they threw me out.
They threw me out of
the Comedy Cellar.
-Wow. And that's a pretty --
And, you know, people say,
"How do you know
it's not going well?"
That's really how you know.
-Yeah.
Go ahead.
-Okay, great. Thank you.
Wow. I don't quite know what --
All right.
-You want me to help you?
-No, I think I got it.
I think this has been
intimate enough.
-Oh!
-There you go.
-Nice.
-Oh, that's -- It's like...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I look like
a sheriff in a musical.
-Yeah.
-This is one of my --
I was at "SNL" in 2012,
when we did a sketch called --
It was a game show called
"Dylan McDermott
or Dermot Mulroney?"
-That's right.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You have --
And now Dermot Mulroney plays
a rival captain on the show,
which is fantastic.
But that was true.
You guys got mistaken
for each other for years.
-I mean, the name has been a
nightmare for 30 years.
-30 years.
-Because you guys
really came on the scene
at almost the exact same time.
-Yeah, that's right.
And it's been painful
for many, many years.
As a matter of fact,
we both were at
William Morris at the time.
Sue Mengers was the biggest
agent in the world at the time.
She came up to me
in the hallway and she said --
Walked right up to me
and she said,
"There can only be one."
And I said, "One what?"
So, she -- "You have to
change your name."
I was like, "Oh, no!"
So, I came up with the
fantastic name of Mick Dermott.
[ Laughter ]
-I am glad, in the end,
that you stood your ground
on your God-given name.
Well, it's very nice that
this 30-year name mix-up
has now collided with
you guys working together.
-That's right.
He finally came on the show.
He was wonderful.
And, you know, we wanted to
finally add more confusion,
which we did.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
Congrats on the show.
Such a pleasure.
-Thank you.